today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i put the link right below
this video
welcome from uh very sunny and beautiful
aruba no i'm kidding it's a pandemic i
don't leave massachusetts right now
uh but there is a lot to talk about last
week i did a story
called we owe the world an apology
and an explanation and that story was
really focused
on having to sort of make good with the
world
for the fact that more than 60 million
americans voted
for donald trump in 2016 and in so doing
unleashed absolutely unconscionable
destruction upon the world that was last
week
and the focus was mostly the micro while
touching on some of the big areas where
the united states has been
really a drag on the world under donald
trump so we talked about climate change
of course we talked about
naturally how could i not mention our
disastrous response to coronavirus but
there's an entire sort of other story to
tell
about the united states under trump
which is less about trump per se
and more about the way in which our
status quo
has been exposed as dangerously fragile
in so many ways which is something that
even people who are not necessarily
trumpists
have been sometimes hesitant to really
consider as seriously as as we should
and of course the virus itself has
exposed a lot of fragility a lot of jobs
that seemed rock solid were not really
rock solid in entire industries quite
frankly were not
as solid as we thought our supply chains
we figured out very quickly are very
fragile
the medical system of course that's
useful to think about
but there's a way more uh sort of
pernicious
fragility that has been exposed
including for example
our alliances with other countries
around the world
this is not coronavirus specifically now
this is what i'd call a sort of trump
fragility allies that we felt were rock
solid
our primary important allies
were very quickly as soon as the united
states
was challenged uh and and was no longer
a reliable predictable partner and
instead we became this sort of erratic
counterproductive fiasco many of our
allies abandoned us now they didn't do
it in a way where they would now be
considered adversaries certainly not but
to different degrees and in their own
ways
we saw what we thought were very solid
alliances
be exposed as extremely fragile very
quickly germany france and canada for
example
realized we can't deal with trump like
an adult
we're actually better off without the
american president
in the room at all when we're having
certain conversations
that's embarrassing and that's bad for
us long term
now i i don't necessarily want to go
directly into a sort of geopolitics game
theory type of analysis
but it is kind of hard to avoid when you
look at what's going on around the world
because when you look at
the superpowers of the world us russia
and china
and you think about the last four years
it's not looking particularly good for
the united states
this may not be your top priority but
if you concede that the most likely
superpower in the world
is likely to be either the u.s china or
russia for some time
a united states that's increasingly
isolated
and losing allies is bad it's bad for
americans as china gains leverage in the
increasingly failed trade war that
donald trump has been waging against
them as russia continues to benefit
uh from the destabilization and the lack
of credibility of american democracy
partially at their own doing of course
we suffer
there's a very good article in rolling
stone from this weekend by wade davis
called the unraveling of america and it
focuses
on this debasement of america in the
context
of coronavirus the article is great but
almost every argument that wade davis
makes and he makes the arguments well
with respect to coronavirus we could
actually apply in the united states more
broadly i'll give you
an example davis says in this article
which you should read in its entirety
the american handling of coronavirus has
called into question the idea
of american exceptionalism i would go
further
our failed response to coronavirus
has confirmed that the idea of american
exceptionalism
was but a shiny band-aid covering up
serious injuries it exposed
many of the cultural failings that
coronavirus has made clear the lack of
our ability to really come together
as a country to do what just needs to be
done even if it's difficult
for the betterment of humanity the
financial fragility
has been exposed wade davis's article
reminds us that almost every empire has
fallen the ends of
empires are rarely anticipated and they
often take a while
but you don't notice that the failing
empire is failing until you look back
later
um it's the united states this time
that needs the world's help as just
about every other country has better
dealt with coronavirus than we have
so what is it that hurt us uh yeah you
know
of course trump's response was a
disaster but there's more there's really
cultural problems
is it too much individualism in the
united states
is it a lack of education or of good
enough education
delusions of grandeur all of the above
yeah probably some component
of all of those so i encourage you to
check out the peace and rolling stone
and if we step back for a moment from
the sort of day-to-day of the trump
administration what has become clear
is that beyond donald trump himself this
type of way of running the country
is not going to allow us to solve the
big problems that we're facing so
in no particular order step back from
coronavirus a little bit
if you think about climate change if you
think about getting everybody healthcare
if you think about ending
optional poverty and hunger which are
optional right now i mean it's just we
we've just not decided to fix them but
hunger and homelessness are optional at
this point in time
um creating government that is not
cronyistic and corrupt
big big things none of those problems
are going to even be seriously explored
from the standpoint of solutions under
an administration like the one we have
it's not just the day-to-day pedestrian
xenophobia
that's an afterthought but it's the
pseudo-intellectualism the
anti-intellectual
the hyper-nationalism the intellectual
isolationism
that's when you look at how every other
country realizes
this is a time to trust science and
doctors and we are isolated
intellectually or
anti-intellectually where you have
people saying fauci and bill gates are
the enemies here
um that's not suited for the 21st
century and beyond and it's hurting us
now
visibly with coronavirus but it's more
about
the list of problems we won't be able to
solve if this is how the united states
operates more broadly
now i know many of you will say well
okay 63 million people voted for this
administration 65
66 voted against it for hillary clinton
that this is not about the electoral
politics this is about a realization of
what is the path forward for humans with
something that is very antiquated and by
the way when i say antiquated
i'm more than willing to entertain the
argument that in times past
this type of mentality made more sense
i'm sensitive to the idea that in early
humanity
many of the traits that now are a
problem were adaptive
from an evolutionary standpoint favoring
these ideas of
you know hyper masculine alpha male
physical violence individualism for
yourself or your small group
isolationism
there was a time in human history where
that made sense and that
is a totally reasonable thing to think
about but it doesn't make sense now and
the people sticking to those
ideas are quite literally stuck in the
past when we say conservatism
what we're talking about is trying to
conserve a way of life
from the past merely because it's what
we used to do
even if it doesn't make any sense now or
in the future and that's exactly where
we are today
a lot to think about when you bring it
back to well
we're less than three months from an
important election
and today i'm going to be outlining some
of the big differences between the
options that we have
in november differences that maybe are
not the ones that are getting the most
attention
so we haven't checked in for a little
bit about what's going on with
coronavirus so i want to spend a little
time today
it's been a weekend we have another
several days of data we now have more
averages and trends to look at
and i want to go a little deeper than
just cases and deaths but let's start
there
as of this morning the united states had
more than 5.2
million confirmed coronavirus cases
and just shy of 166 000 deaths
now remember that in terms of deaths
donald trump
said through april and may first he said
15 cases will soon be zero that didn't
work out
in april may donald trump said well we
could end up with 50 or 60 000 deaths
then it became clear it's going to be
more trump moved the goal post to 70 80
000. 90 100 000. now it's about keeping
it under two hundred thousand now
the official death toll at 166 later in
the show
i'm going to talk to you about the
actual death toll now
really is probably more like 225 because
of the uncounted coronavirus deaths
let me not get ahead of myself we'll get
to that a little bit later but okay that
we're officially at 166
000. now in terms of cases per capita
the states now at the top of the list
are louisiana arizona
florida new york mississippi new jersey
alabama georgia
south carolina rhode island and nevada
and what you're seeing is that what
early
in terms of per capita cases were
exclusively these blue state
hot spots as a result of which states
have
the direct flights to the source
contagion regions
there's been a shift to red states not
just in the total number of cases but in
cases per capita
because now it's about policy early it
was about who had the bad
luck or timing is what i guess i would
call it
uh to before we really knew about the
virus
have a lot of direct flights to china
and the source countries in europe like
italy and it was
you know boston new york new jersey area
chicago illinois
the california airports rhode island by
virtue of being very close to boston
also was hit very hard
now it's about who's testing
who has guidelines where are people
wearing masks etc so
now it's about policy cases of course
depend on tests and how much testing you
are doing
and as we know as i told you last week
florida and california as examples
were under reporting cases for different
reasons florida because of the hurricane
california
for still some unknown reason so when
you look at one of these examples let's
look at for example
florida because of the decreased testing
in florida
florida cases started declining in late
july
except we know why they aren't testing
as much because of the hurricane
but if you look instead of it cases at
hospitalizations
during the last week florida had a
record
for single week new hospitalizations for
coronavirus just over 3 300 that's more
than
500 new hospitalizations per day
including 621 hospitalizations
in florida last wednesday that's not
what you want to see
and it's another signal of how you can
affect cases by not testing
by changing reporting hospitalizations
are a really important indicator now
meanwhile
for political reasons donald trump is
talking about
every country now is seeing a resurgence
and the reason trump is doing this is if
he can point to
spain is having a wave 2 italy's having
a wave 2.
i guess he thinks it makes the united
states response look less
bad but there's a few really important
things to think about as we look at some
european countries
see numbers start to climb again first
of all we've been expecting a second
wave
since march this was what doctors
thought would happen
decrease in the summer back up as we
approach fall
in the u.s we never even had the gap
because when we got down to 20 000 cases
per day
most states started reopening which is
crazy
now to the other piece yes if you look
at
some european countries now like spain
they are seeing a resurgence in cases
but they're immediately putting the
guidelines back in place
and people are mostly following them so
when the president points to
we're doing fine because there are
second waves in europe well
first reaction is we knew and expected
all along that there would be a second
wave
in the us we've been so acutely terrible
that we didn't even get a break from
wave one to wave two
and we're now approaching the fall
ourselves secondly
the other countries see the rise and
they put the guidelines back in place
paris is now ramping back up masking
rules and putting measures back in place
trump points to spain and france to
justify not
having taken it seriously but the
problem with his logic
is they did take it seriously and
immediately are starting to right away
it's completely incoherent
but it's where we are today and all we
can do is deal with it
real quick uh august 23rd
is the 15-year anniversary of the david
pakman show this is a really big deal
we're on track for a million youtube
subscribers this year
our podcast has grown 40 percent in the
last three months
and we're hitting 15 years so on the
23rd
we will have a huge very special
membership special which you can be
notified of by grabbing
a free newsletter subscription at
davidpakman.com
this is very exciting we're doing
something crazy that i may even regret
some governors would probably call the
membership special we're planning
illegal and immoral i would even say but
we're going to persevere and do it so
get on our newsletter at davidpakman.com
august 23rd a big big day
in david pakman show history the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
today's new members of the day are aaron
brown
and andrew reed thanks guys for your
support i very much appreciate it and
also a big thank you to heather
ires who is today's long time sustaining
member of the day grab a membership
at joinpackman.com let me ask you a
question what do you think is the real
coronavirus
death toll it appears it could be more
than 54
000 deaths higher than the official
death toll and i'm going to explain
how the cdc data points us to that
conclusion in a second
but at least to start theoretically
anytime you have something
as big as a pandemic which infects more
than 5 million people in the united
states we're at 5.2 million official
cases
it's a country of more than 330 million
people people die
every day for coronavirus and other
reasons there are co-morbidities there
are other factors
it's going to be unlikely that the
official death toll
is exactly what the real death toll is
for the virus
now on the one side there are conspiracy
theories from the right
that are about deception and politics
where they say
the real death toll is much lower it's
not 166 000 it's much smaller
they claim this is not me this is the
argument some on the right make
a lot of deaths are being counted as
coronavirus and they're really not
and they'll talk about someone died in a
car crash and
a hospital counted it as coronavirus
because they get more money that way or
whatever or democrats are lying and
blowing up the death rate
in order to make political uh points or
whatever the case may be now you should
be
skeptical of that theory and indeed
there's no
evidence for that theory other than if
you want to be anecdotal
there might be cases where it's not a
car accident but
you know it's an infection caused by a
comorbidity and an elderly person who
had coronavirus and
maybe there's like some debate as to
should this or shouldn't this count
as a coronavirus death but these are
small numbers of situations in a country
with 5.2 million infections
you're bound to have some anecdotes like
that but on the other side
there's a much more compelling reason to
think the real coronavirus death toll
is dramatically higher than the official
and it is something called
excess deaths the number of extra deaths
during the march to july period suggests
that more than 54 000 additional people
have died of coronavirus be above and
beyond the
uh official death toll this is derived
when you look at
excess deaths and in the united states
because we have so many people
and so many years of data and such
detailed
statistics about disease we know how
many people on
average will die of all causes based on
our population based on what's called
the normal amount of death
we know okay if you add up expected car
accident deaths cancer deaths heart
disease flu altogether
we know when you don't have a pandemic
how many people typically die
and if you look at the deaths we would
expect from march 15th
to july 25th you see that during those
dates there were almost 201 000
excess deaths deaths beyond what we
would normally have
and during that time the official
coronavirus death toll
was only 147 thousand that leaves about
54 000 extra deaths not officially
attributed
to coronavirus now epidemiologists
favor looking at excess deaths
to gauge the impact of a pandemic
because excess deaths don't depend on
testing people and knowing exactly who
had the virus posthumous testing
testing when someone goes into the
hospital etc
and indeed when you look at excess
deaths everything tracks consistently
with this
theory if you look at where the excess
deaths disproportionately are
it's in the state's hardest hit by
coronavirus and it is a very coherent
story that excess death analysis points
us to
so in all likelihood the real
coronavirus death toll
right now is at least 54 000 deaths
higher than the original one
it's even more because that was march 15
to july 25.
in the two weeks since july 25 we've had
a resurgence in deaths and in all
likelihood there are more
uncounted deaths during that period so
what is the likely real coronavirus
death toll remember official is 166.
it's probably somewhere around 225 to
235
and rapidly approaching 250 000 deaths
we are going to have to accept that the
death toll
is much higher than many think when the
pandemic is so widespread
when tests are still today taking five
to seven days or longer to come
back with results we know we aren't
capturing all the cases
and therefore it follows we're not
capturing all the deaths either
we later will have to see what is the
long-term
impact on the lungs on the heart
on other systems from having and
recovering from coronavirus because you
could have a situation
where years down the line there are
premature deaths
caused by damage done to vital organs
by coronavirus we don't know the extent
of that yet that's something
the medical community is looking at any
deaths are tragic
we have many unnecessary deaths due to
the failed trump response
but we also just have to face the
reality that by now
we probably have somewhere between 55
and 60 000 deaths
that are not in the official death count
which are
due to coronavirus which gets us to
what happens in november and how is the
right
trying to get themselves reelected
despite donald trump's failed response
let's talk about that next
we started to predict this months ago
when it became clear that vote by mail
or
as i am now calling it absentee by mail
voting
would be a huge dividing line in the
upcoming presidential election
also don't forget it will be a big deal
in the senate
maybe remaining in republican control
maybe going to democratic control
they are going to be trying to stop
vote by mail and stop absentee voting
they're not even trying to hide it i
already told you that donald trump put a
donor of his name
louis de joy in charge of the post
office as postmaster general we
suspected
that de joy would try to hurt the post
office's ability
to deliver mail the joy has already
limited
overtime for mail carriers which is
causing mail to pile up at post offices
across the country
more cutbacks are now being discussed
but now the big breaking news is that
the joy
has reassigned or fired more than two
dozen
top postal officials specifically
two people have been removed 23 have
been reassigned
anyone whose priorities are deliver the
mail
is being moved and instead de joy seems
to be sort of
centralizing his power consolidating the
higher echelons of the postal service
with people that are friendly to his
pro-trump priorities and this is the
mail that we're talking about ladies and
gentlemen if i had told you a year ago
the 2020 presidential election could
come down not to the economy
uh not to donald trump's foreign policy
it could come down to whether
a trump donor succeeds at kneecapping
and crippling the post office i don't
think any of us would have believed that
that was a likely scenario
it's the scenario today and this is all
having an immediate effect there are
already many reports
coming in from around the country about
mail delivery being slowed down and
degraded
there are reports of mail carriers
having to sort mail themselves something
that's usually done for them when they
arrive and
they're ready to take out their mail for
the day it would already be sorted
they're having to sort it themselves
slows them down even more there are
reports of mail bins that should have
been delivered already sitting
at post offices unsorted and undelivered
and the sickest thing of it all
is the backwards logic of everything
trump claimed
that if there were too many absentee
ballots the post office couldn't handle
the volume of mail
the post office said we can handle it
just fine unless
you kneecap the post office which is
exactly what they're doing they are
making
it so that the post office will not be
able to handle
even the normal mail delivery work it's
like a trojan horse
you don't have to be i hope you don't
have to be anti-trump to realize how
evil this is
right right i mean will a pro trump uh
will will the pro
trump people in my audience i know
you're there will you come forward and
say this is playing dirty
this is anti-democratic this has to be
stopped it's
completely indefensible and this they
talk about election fraud
this should be called election fraud so
what can we do
while we continue to sound the alarm on
this
and demand that joy be trotted back to
congress to answer questions
we have to just vote early early early
or
decide we feel safe enough to vote in
person depending on where you live
you within just weeks we'll be able to
make a vote by mail
if it gets delayed five days because of
these cuts it'll still get there in
plenty of time
if you live in a state where you can
believe reasonably that you won't have
to spend hours
in line with maskless people trying to
vote
maybe you decide well i'll vote in
person to ensure my vote is counted in
some places you will be waiting in line
for hours with people without masks
and maybe you don't want to do that and
it makes sense to just vote by mail as
early as you can
all of these problems are by design we
can't let them win
at all but we certainly can't let them
win like this
anyone who does not have a problem with
this is complicit in the eradication of
democracy
in this case being done through the
proxy of the u.s postal service
trump is realizing the race is too
uncertain
unless he rigs it as i said last week
trump might be able to win fair and
square
although unlikely that he would win the
popular vote
he might be able to win the electoral
college fair and square maybe
but it's too close it's too risky and so
they're pulling out all the stops
this is also by the way part of a bigger
republican plan to get rid of government
agencies altogether
say that the united states postal
service is not up to the job
then you cut their funding to prevent
them from being up to the job
then you point to the problems you
caused to say you know we really should
get rid of that postal service they're
not doing a good job
look at what they did during the 2020
election we have to be
on red alert because that's exactly what
this is we'll have continued coverage of
this on the david pakman show
instagram at david pakman show we'll
take a quick break
and be right back after this the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the world
famous bonus show as well as commercial
free audio and video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
okay this is a huge deal so we're gonna
spend some time on this
donald trump admitted during one of his
weekend press briefings from his club in
bedminster new jersey
where he gathered a crowd of supporters
to cheer for him during a press briefing
and to boo reporters i mean
this is it's complete the country is
backwards right now okay
he said he is going to be permanently
cutting funding to social security and
medicare
how did he say it take a look because it
might not be obvious
if i'm victorious on november 3rd i plan
to forgive these taxes and make
permanent cuts
to the payroll tax so i'm going to make
them all permanent wait a second
did he say social security there how
what how is this about social security
let me explain it to you donald trump is
finally admitting here
that if he is re-elected he will
permanently cut
the employee side of the social security
deduction from wages
this is how social security is funded
this is a huge red alert this is not
getting the attention it deserves and
what's crazy is
you still have some people including
people on the left
saying biden will cut your social
security if he's president
not something biden has even talked
about for 27 years
since 1993 during which he said he
wouldn't preemptively take it off the
table
this is donald trump saying i am going
to permanently reduce
the money that is the primary funding
source
for social security so let's talk it
through earlier in the pandemic donald
trump started talking about
waiving the so-called payroll tax for
employees through the end of the year
that tax is shared between you and your
employer if you are
self-employed you pay all of it but for
most people they're a w-2 employee
for example like producer pat pat pays
7.65 out of his salary
and then i put in another 7.65 percent
for him it's a total of 15.3 percent
it's mostly social security and a little
bit for medicare that's how we
fund social security so trump floats the
idea hey pandemic economics are disaster
let's put more money in people's pockets
by cutting
the 7.65 paid by the employee
immediately the employees get to keep
another 7.65
from every paycheck great but the way
that it was originally conceived
was a deferral meaning you get that
money in your paycheck through the end
of the year
but when you file your taxes in 2021 for
2020
you owe that back it was just a deferral
it gets added back in
wasn't even permanent it's a temporary
savings and then you get a bill for it
now trump is again going for the payroll
tax idea he's looking at it via
executive order which he said when
barack obama was president
is being overused that he wouldn't do
things through executive order he'd do
them through legislation except he's not
doing it
but except he says he'll give you the
payroll tax deferral for now
if he's re-elected he will forgive
the repayment of the payroll tax we
think i mean it's so convoluted that
even trump has gone back and forth on
some of these points
but now again he says in the future if
he's reelected he will just
cut the employee side altogether here he
is
saying it again if i'm victorious on
november 3rd i plan to forgive these
taxes and make permanent cuts
to the payroll tax i'm going to make
them more permanent i plan
to forgive these taxes and make
permanent cuts
this is a shadow plan to cut
social security and medicare this is a
red alert
republicans already say social
security's in trouble it's underfunded
it won't be able to pay benefits
what do you think happens if you cut the
money going in
you obviously will have to cut the
benefits so now we have a dramatically
different proposal from donald trump
versus
joe biden on social security trump wants
permanent cuts to social security taxes
meaning
he will have to lower social security
benefits he's looking to neuter social
security
a fabric of our country really it's i
mean you know other countries have much
stronger social safety nets one of the
things we have
one of the few things is social security
trump wants to neuter it
biden wants to uncap social security
taxes
above four hundred thousand dollars
normally you only pay payroll tax
on the first hundred and thirty thousand
or so of earnings
that means if you normally earn a
million dollars
you only paid the social security tax on
the first hundred and thirty k
above that you pay zero biden's idea is
you pay on the first hundred and thirty
there's then like a donut hole
between 130 and 400 but starting at 400
000 a year in income uncapped
you pay that 7.65 that's
a huge increase in funding for social
security
versus donald trump saying he will
permanently defund it
this is a topic which is not getting
huge air time
right now and we need to force it to get
more attention
hopefully it will be a big part of the
debates between trump and biden if they
happen
because it is of such huge significance
to the vast majority of the united
states just think back
trump was supposedly the economic
populist big populism wonderful
populism from donald trump he is now
saying if you re-elect him
he will neuter permanently social
security
and you can take to the bank the
realization that shortly thereafter
they're going to say hey
we gave you the payroll tax people are
getting the money up front but
we're going to have to cut social
security benefits as a result we're no
longer funding it
to the extent that we previously were
don't allow this issue to be ignored
democrats need to run hard with this all
the way to november and you know that
republicans would do the exact same
thing
if democrats suggested even smaller
changes
to programs they believe are important
this is an attempt at a massive
destruction
of one of the most important programs
that exist in the united states
to even maintain financial solvency for
so many millions of
americans once they hit retirement so
we're continuing
sort of our tour through the absolutely
outrageous things that donald trump said
during his rally-like press briefings at
his
own golf club over the weekend and yes
this is reality as far as we know
and one of the things he said and that
he's been saying more and more
is he's going to protect people with
pre-existing conditions now you might
hear that and say wait
i remember this debate from 10 years ago
obamacare protects people with
pre-existing conditions and you would be
right
one of the big accomplishments of
obamacare that
is very popular with the entire country
it's not just democrats that like the
pre-existing condition
provision is that obamacare made it the
law
that health insurance companies can't
reject you because you have a
pre-existing condition they can't reject
coverage of that pre-existing condition
this is so popular that now donald trump
is just claiming he's going to do it by
executive order
except of course it's already the law
check this out it's really beyond belief
so over the next two weeks i'll be
pursuing a major executive order
requiring
health insurance companies to cover all
pre-existing conditions
for all customers that's a big thing
i've always been very strongly in favor
we have to cover pre-existing conditions
so we will be pursuing a major
executive order requiring health
insurance companies to cover all
pre-existing conditions
for all of its customers this has never
been done before but it's time the
people of our country are properly
represented
and properly taken care of now you're
not mishearing that
trump is promising to do something that
is already the law
thanks to obamacare if you can believe
this
trump saying this was reported as
breaking news by some media outlets it
was breaking news 10 years ago when the
affordable care act was first signed
into law
meanwhile trump's own administration is
suing
to try to dismantle the affordable care
act which is what protects people with
pre-existing conditions
we've never seen anything like this
before we really haven't and part of why
is because of who's in the white house
part of why is because of who supports
this guy
we've never seen anything like this
before trump is saying
i will sign an executive order to
enforce the law from 2010
which i've been trying to repeal since i
became president of the united states
the provision trump wants to make law
with an executive order
is pre-existing if you can imagine that
we've had it for a decade now i actually
do not think that this is
trump being stupid uh this was a speech
that was on paper in front of him right
trump didn't just come up with this out
of thin air
he doesn't write the speeches obviously
this is a calculation
that he can do the same thing with
pre-existing conditions that he's been
doing with veterans choice
there i think it's been a dozen times or
so that donald trump has said when asked
about his accomplishments from his first
term he says veterans choice
now veterans choice is an obama
accomplishment from 2014
and trump has taken credit for it a
dozen maybe two dozen times
similarly here coverage of pre-existing
conditions is very popular with
americans as it should be
and donald trump is going to try to take
credit for it to get himself
reelected he's throwing everything at
the wall to see what sticks
and what might help him in november
plain and simple nothing more nothing
less
and we know he will try to take credit
for a coronavirus vaccine which is
likely to enter emergency use
sometime around the election no thanks
to donald trump
we know trump will try to take credit
for any treatment including ones
that were tested mostly in other
countries if they end
up being effective to deal with
coronavirus and he might get away with
it that's the understanding
we can't realize trump will try to take
credit for this stuff and laugh and say
ah
nobody's gonna fall for that no 63
million people voted for him in 2016.
63 million people already fell for it
there are clearly millions of americans
who will
believe that trump cured coronavirus or
found a vaccine or protected
pre-existing conditions
because they believe anything he says
and that's
what the next three months have to be
all about
which is to overwhelm the vote to such a
degree
that none of these bamboozlings and lies
actually help
donald trump to get reelected or they'll
help him
but they won't actually get him over the
hump the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers
and listeners and one way to keep us
going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about them
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so the one other moment i want to show
you from this trump propaganda press
briefing that he did over the weekend
that is
that is a bedminster golf club goes
very simply to donald trump's completely
thin skin and his
complete inability to face any serious
challenges to his lies now if you
watched the jonathan swan
axios interview recently you already
know that donald trump completely
implodes when
subjected to even the most minor
fact-checking but
in the interview with jonathan swann he
wasn't really able to do
what he did when cbs's paula reed
confronted him now as i told you
in the last segment donald trump has
been regularly taking credit for barack
obama's policy veterans choice
obama signed it into law in 2014 trump
regularly takes credit for it as if it's
something that he did
well cbs news's paula reed was not
having it and she called him out
and you will see how donald trump
reacted about being confronted about
such an obvious and overt lie he does
not take it well
take a look how do you keep saying that
you pass
veterans
thank you very much everybody thank you
very much
so trump just walks off abruptly
this is how fragile authoritarian
dictators behave
they pretend to be alpha and powerful
and then when their wild claims are
subjected to scrutiny
they abort the situation essentially now
in some places they'll also have the
journalist killed
i don't expect that to happen to paula
reed but trump shrinks like a frightened
turtle and recedes into his shell
this persona of big power and strength
uh very quickly falls apart when you
confront him
and make him face his obvious lies and
in this case donald trump just walks off
now it also shouldn't be ignored
that the entire setup for this with the
crowd of club-goers
cheering trump and booing the media it's
scaling up
yet another level the degree of
sycophancy that's constructed around
donald trump all the time but i actually
think that this is something reporters
should use to their advantage
we've now seen trump end press
conferences multiple times when a
reporter
is allowed by other reporters to follow
up
and what trump counts on is that when
he's done with reporter number one
even if they try to follow up i was
going to say even if she tries to follow
up
usually this tends to happen with women
he'll go to the next reporter
and the next reporter is often so
desperate to ask their question that
they just immediately launch in
but when it doesn't happen when a
reporter says no no you can follow up
it's often led to the end of a press
briefing i remember this happened to
cbs's weijia jiang
who was i believe caitlyn collins from
cnn
allowed wagia to follow up about
something related to china that trump
said to her and she's chinese-american
and
it didn't go well this happened to
caitlin collins
when she was allowed to follow up by
another reporter and trump tried to move
on
ended up bailing on the press briefing
and it's happened several times
and again this weekend and reporters
should really make an implicit agreement
with themselves
let's allow each other to follow up even
when donald trump tries to call on the
next person
and then he's going to end up bailing
all together even more than he does
when he is confronted by facts he
frequently runs away
and yet many of his 63 million
supporters from 2016
still see a strong alpha male there and
seeing this
actually makes me curious about trump's
interest in debating he had to debate in
2016
there was no way in 2016 as the
challenger
as the non-incumbent to say i'm not
going to debate hillary clinton i don't
think he could have gotten away with it
but right now donald trump clearly does
not want counterpoints
he doesn't want a scenario in which he
could be called out about his lies or
fact
check to any degree my expectation
is that if donald trump does debate his
team will work
very hard to keep the rebuttals short
and to put in place
all sorts of rules that will favor trump
including no fact
by the moderators and um
if not i would not be surprised to see
him find a reason
out of the debates the most likely
scenario is he will get what he wants
and the debates will happen
a trump's economic advisor larry kudlow
was visibly confused
and sounded off uh when it came to
simple arithmetic on cnn yesterday i
think you'll find this disturbing
because
it is wild confusion about basic numbers
combined with a very odd delivery from
larry kudlow which we'll talk about in a
moment now the setup is that there's
been a debate
about what is the next stimulus package
going to include
when is the next stimulus package going
to happen
what's the unemployment piece and how
does it all
fit together larry kudlow puts together
a word salad where it's not even clear
he knows the numbers he certainly can't
express
them but it's not even clear he knows
what the numbers are cnn's dana bash
tries to figure out what the hell is
larry kudlow talking about
she can't do it kudlow is confused and
it all falls apart
today so when will people see their
first checks
uh i don't want to be specific because
you might hold me to it
as you should but i think it's going to
be in a couple of weeks
and i think it's going to come to about
twelve hundred dollars per person
uh that's a huge saying twelve hundred
dollars per person
are you talking about in addition to the
unemployment that they're already
getting
oh no number one payroll that
i'm i beg your pardon the twelve hundred
dollars will come from the payroll tax
deficit
we're gonna get to that okay all right
because this is there's a lot of
numbers here and it's it's it's a little
confusing i'm gonna give you a few tax
in a minute
go ahead it should be 800 bucks i beg
your pardon it should be 800 bucks
for the unemployment 800 or 400
no it should be four it should be eight
hundred dollars
if the states step up we're prepared to
match
that should be come out four hundred
dollars federal
400 states
okay we'll move on because i think this
is
that's not what the president said and
it's a bit confusing um and i think the
fact that it's not entirely known is
very telling
1200 per person payroll tax deferral
wait no stimulus actually it should be
800 for unemployment
no it we're prepared to match 400
federal and 400 state
but we're matching wait but what does
that even mean you're matching 400
federal there's really nothing federal
to match it's all state when it comes to
unemployment
and then the federal match or
enhancement is of state unemployment
insurance
if you think i sound confused yes it's
because it's this insane what larry
kudlow is saying
he's saying there's a state match and a
federal match what does that even mean
and dana bash just white flags she
surrenders
and she says let's move on this is
totally confusing
it's not what donald trump is saying now
the second layer is that not only is
larry kudlow presenting this
in a completely impossible to understand
way
it also seems to be completely different
from what the trump uh
what donald trump himself has said and
when we talk about
this matching the feds contribute 300
if the states add another hundred but
i'm
trying to sort out something as if it's
at all clear
and kudlow just was slightly uh
confused he seems to have no idea what's
going on whatsoever and it gets even
worse during this interview here's a
similar confusion about the payroll tax
deferral
not a cut a deferral and larry kudlow
equally confused but the president said
explicitly that if he gets re-election
re-elected he will make the payroll tax
cut permanent
as you well know these funds these funds
go into and help pay for social security
and medicare the president promised
many times not to get social security
and medicare
so isn't that exactly what he would be
doing here
no he will protect social security and
medicare how does he do that and cut
payroll taxes at the same time
well hang on uh when he referred to
permanent
i think what he was saying is that
the deferral of the payroll tax to the
end of the year
will be made permanent it will be
forgiven the tax is not going away we're
still going to have he said he would
he said he would you're still protecting
if he gets reelected it was a new
campaign pledge but
i i i no i i think that he was referring
doing away with it i believe he was
referring
to doing away with the payback of the
deferral
and i think his intent here and it's
written in the uh eos
very clear that we will take uh any
steps possible
to forgive this deferral that's what he
was actually saying
we will just want to say i just want to
say that's what you're saying medicare
that is not that is not what the
president said at all
um he said that he said that he's the
executive order
okay so that's not what he said people
aren't reading the executive order
they're they're listening to this well i
think he's listening
i think he meant the deferral would be
forgiven i think he was saying that
that the savings on the deferral will be
permanent he did not mean
that he's eliminating the social
security tax it's a deferral
that will be forgiven without doing away
with the tax
but trump said he would do away with it
if he's re-elected
but that's not what trump meant
according to kudlow
if you were confused and you were
confused
further by my explanation good it's
outrageously confusing and deceptive and
this is either
it's either or both you take your pick
they're either
all deliberately saying different things
in order to sort of let
everybody take their pick and if they
hear one version that sounds okay
they like it and they say i approve or
they actually don't know what the hell
is going on and everybody's saying
something different or some combination
right that that's always a possibility
uh we need
to hear from kudlow what trump meant
apparently i mean kudlow is saying what
the president
meant is this absolutely outrageous and
bizarre now i do have to mention one
thing to go back to
larry kudlow's demeanor here people have
been emailing me saying
is kudlow drunk again during this
interview i understand why you are
asking larry kudlow does have a history
of
problems when it comes to alcohol
consumption that's not anything to laugh
at
i don't know the answer in this case but
certainly it's not a crazy thing
to wonder about with larry kudlow his
thinking clearly seemed impaired he was
visibly confused by the arithmetic
and by what he's saying and by what he's
being asked and by what donald trump
said and by what donald trump meant
it's a you know a verbal inkblot as i
like to say
as far as the alcohol piece is concerned
i don't know i it's it's up to others to
evaluate and judge his thinking was
impaired
by what is definitely a different
question that i guess we will have to
leave
uh presumably for a different day
we have a voicemail number which you can
call
really any time of day and there's
people who call it at times that i tend
to be asleep and that's fine and we love
it
that number is 219 to david p recently
on the bonus show
there were some comments made by
producer pat
which many in our audience were
titillated by
including about pat's jujitsu
proficiency
and pat's height and weight and one of
the people that was very much
taken by it was the egg man who had the
following to say
hi dave i recently learned that pat is
six
foot two 202 pounds and a jiu jitsu
expert
damn dave did you hire him as a producer
or your bodyguard
fellow brother right exactly and i think
that you know in in uh
in executive security a really great
thing
is when you can't tell who is actually
security is that a staffer
is that a policy person or or is that
security so yes
eggman clearly on to something and of
course pat's training
has all been to develop a very
particular set of skills that will be
useful not intellectually but also
physically and to keep everybody very
very safe on the bonus show today
i don't know how many people in the
audience saw this crazy
jerry falwell jr picture
with his pants unbuttoned a very strange
thing i really don't care about jerry
falwell jr
in any way other than the fact that he
is or was a higher up at liberty
university
the son of one of the most vile now the
late
jerry falwell senior one of the most
vile sort of evangelical hard right
lunatics who blamed 911 on gay people
and women having abortions i mean these
are really vile people and then now
jerry falwell
in the heat of some real problems and we
will talk about that
also in georgia a teenager took
pictures of crowding in the hallways at
school
on the first day back and was suspended
for it
okay she pointed out
how badly things are being managed in
the school
she pointed out that she's not safe and
she was suspended if you can imagine
this has exploded she was interviewed
and we're going to talk about
how she is now actually receiving
threats and should it surprise us
if dr fauci's daughters are receiving
threats
obviously a kid who exposes the lack of
safety measures
in georgia schools given what's going on
in georgia given governor kemp's
uh lack of of adherence to the facts and
empiricism
i don't think we should be surprised
that she is now receiving threats
and in the meantime amazon which is a
company that is doing very well during
the pandemic because people want to
have things delivered to their homes
amazon is reportedly discussing using
former jcpenney and sears stores both
uh big box chains that have suffered
greatly recently thanks to the online
uh boom amazon's looking at using
jcpenney and see your stores as
fulfillment centers
which there's like a sort of coming full
circle aspect to what we're seeing
in the business world lately amazon now
opening physical bookstores if you can
imagine
after destroying so many local
bookstores so all of those stories and
more we will discuss on today's bonus
show
two ways to get instant access to the
bonus show become a member
at joinpackman.com or become a patron at
patreon.com
slash david pakman show also you can
continue to follow my
training for the chess.com pogchamps 2
tournament
with my live streams at twitch.tv
david pakman and on august 23rd
the 15 year anniversary of the david
pakman show
we will be blowing out a huge membership
special
related to the number 15 because it is
after all our 15-year anniversary
to be notified about that amazing
membership special
make sure to be on our newsletter list
which you can sign up for
at davidpakman.com i will see you on the
bonus show
otherwise tomorrow
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor is blinkist
the app that lets you read or listen to
an entire nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
for free
and save 25 off of a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link
right underneath this video